what is it
um
like
there's people not like official term
sheets but you know like people that
would actually like be able to afford it
like yeah you know a billion dollars if
we could own the channel and the
companies and stuff like that like and
I'm like oh
that sounds enticing but I don't know if
I want to work for my YouTube channel
yeah um but I yeah I'm pretty sure
you've been offered a billion dollars
for your YouTube channel well with all
the companies yeah but not like again
not a term sheet but like people who
would if I took it serious they would
have been like okay let's figure it out
would that make you the youngest
billionaire would that beat Zuckerberg
uh I think he was just a self-made
billionaire yeah because there are a lot
of people who are handed down well and
Kylie Jenner but yeah if you count her
she was 21 but outside of her if you
Google it's like some guy that's 26. wow
yeah so you you got offered a b bro
basically in passing but and I know I
could have pushed for something around
this streaming company or I could I
could go any further than that but I
mean I feel pretty confident someone I
mean just look at it like I told you the
piece for your number actually
for 10 years it'll be five bill or
hopefully more but yeah what's your
number right now
uh it's so crazy I don't even want to
say it because it's just I'm thinking
where I want to be like if we have a
mobile game company and I can just you
know we got 100 million people playing
it and we got a thousand physical Beast
burgers and peaceables is in 20 000
stores but then it's not crazy so say
What's the number that's gonna dude
similar to some dumb but like probably
like 10 billion 20 billion at least 100
million people playing yeah
yeah but that's where if they give me
the money now but obviously in the
future I think we could be worth way
more but not that that's like the end
goal but it's just crazy you're worth
more than WhatsApp
that's your number and it's reasonable
I'm nowhere near that but obviously yeah
can you let me [ __ ] do this no
because that's exactly comparison get
five years yes yeah wow or ten maybe I'm
just shocked that Disney hasn't said can
we have back catalog can we have access
to back just a license just a license
think about if I'm a licensing dog [ __ ]
but if I'm a parent and I know that I
can just give my kid an app I don't want
you searching all the crazy [ __ ] on the
internet you end up watching a flagrant
video
I want an app that has all this content
that I know that'll be okay for my kid
to watch and it won't be too too [ __ ]
crazy whatever yeah like are you telling
me that isn't worth a few hundred
million just to have access to the
catalog
I can keep it on YouTube if you're still
they also have it and they can do
whatever they want monetize it whatever
way that they want they can put together
put it on their streaming services I
think we're gonna do a Netflix show
eventually we've just been busy I think
after we do that that's where it'll be
interesting or maybe I'll do one and
then I'll sell it on my own you already
did I'm kidding I'm kidding that's the
Coco melon thing right yeah I just want
to do one because there are just a lot
of older people that watch Netflix that
don't watch us and YouTube's not great
for episodic content so like if I wanted
to do something where I feel a stadium
with 10 000 people and it's 10 episodes
in every episode we eliminate 10 of them
like that would fit better on Netflix
then you have to do something that fits
the magnitude of the space yeah one I
can do episodes because people go to
Netflix to watch multiple episodes
people go to YouTube for like right now
like that give me the [ __ ] off so I have
a bunch of episodic stuff like that that
I would love to do on Netflix because
it's just a better platform for it
um and I just love to hit a news that's
right because you might not get the
retention if you have an eight episode
Arc of a YouTuber you're gonna open up
YouTube and be recommended episode four
yeah I hate when they do that that
always happens part three and I'm like
where the [ __ ] is it possible that's the
one reception with YouTube is like for
scripted stuff like that like if you
were to do a script well it's not even
scripted but yeah right but if you were
to do a scripted show yeah YouTube is
prioritizing that retention the
click-through rate the watch time that
might not necessarily last well I also
do want to do animations because I think
I have some funny ass ideas I think
would do really well if we made some
short films yeah um like uh [ __ ] one of
them this one's a short and easy one
obviously a banger I think I should do
an animation obviously yeah yeah well if
if it was like an animation where it's
just me and I I fly like 100 Youtubers
down to an island for like a paintball
Battle Royale which is what I did before
but in this animation instead of giving
them like paintball guns
so it's like an evil like song and it's
like you know if someone doesn't die
every hour I just pick someone random
they die and it's whoever wins wins the
island so that so it would start off
with me like that's how I lure them all
their 100 million dollar Island winner
watch them with Island we got Logan KSI
everyone there yeah and then it's just
like you know like a saw level story and
then whoever ends up winning oh I love
the dark yeah
I think that would be going I have a
couple others the only problems I told
you I know for a fact don't let people
yeah yeah is it like an anime like I
know you like like definitely would love
to make an anime yeah it's like
um well here just cut this part I'll
tell you it and then at the end show is
reaction Kick-Ass story it's a great
story movie too it's like 10 episodes
we're back in now yeah yeah we're back
now that's fine yeah yeah I have a ton
of those them sit on that I think would
be great for like so these are all
episodic Concepts that you have yeah
exactly I want to do animation in the
future like do basically like Pixar
because I think would be great yeah and
that would be fire has there been an
episodic cartoon
like a long form not like a I don't
think it's called episodic uh I mean any
like anime yeah everything anime is like
that there's like a 10 episode
infinite you're gonna look like yeah
there's probably 20 million examples
anything in English
now that I'm saying that we grew up
watching like for example like The
Simpsons isn't really episodic you're
not fall every episode is not dependent
on the last one and X-Men like all those
yeah but that's not like I'm talking
about Dragon Ball Z would be one yeah
there is one storyline that you're
Following Season Dragon Ball Z yeah it's
a perfect example okay because Marvel is
one episode you fight one bad guy then
he's done then the next episode you find
another bad guys there's there's
episodic and there's another procedural
procedural I think most of our cartoons
were procedural because they knew the
kids weren't gonna maybe tune in one
Saturday because you've got to be able
to just run it and you can't just run it
all at the same I like this this
episodic idea I think that's fire agreed
so I want to do a lot of that and
actually show that I I know how to do
storytelling yeah a lot of people
confuse our lack of conforming to like
what does well on this platform to like
not knowing how to tell a good story and
so that's what does well